the point was that did not kill the
rabbit for fun we killed it in order to
eat it just like we every day killed
thousands of animals in order to eat
them that's a very important point they
did not kill the rabbit and throw it out
they killed the rabbit in order to eat
it because that's what we do that's what
we human people do human / human beings
two triangles we tend to do that there
in slaughterhouses or we do it in other
environments that are created for that
thing as opposed to in a radio studio
with a bike pump all we tend to do it at
the Riverside with the fish or at a farm
when you kill a chicken I've been doing
that because I lived on a farm and I
kill chicken with a stick and an axe
that's that's what you do but that's
also how you kill animals what is the
important thing is none of a lot of
people doesn't seem to care about how
these animals lived then they don't they
don't care about animal welfare for the
livestock at a lot of farms that's the
interesting point what about taste and
decency yeah to specify the question you
asked me the question before and I think
I answered no you answered previously
about the final moments being played out
and also the guests trying to save the
animal or otherwise I'm asking you
specifically now about taste and decency
you didn't answer that when I asked you
previously I i think this rabbit had a
very decent life it was taking good care
of it had a nice life it was killed in a
decent way instructed by a person from a
cigar what about the taste and decent
seat for your listeners and the fact
that so many of them appears to have
complained and it's caused an opera yeah
that's us as I said before that's the
interesting point that we tend not to
care about the killing every day of lots
of animals who has a very very poor life
who has no animal welfare at all but we
care about this rabbit it was raised it
had a good life it was killed in a
decent way and it was eating uh are you
planning on killing any other animals in
the studio nope why not
because this is not about killing
animals in the studio as I told you this
was about raising a discussion about
animal welfare and in certain ways of
the hypocrisy between some animal and
their welfare or lack of welfare and
other animals yeah but you wanted to
shock your audience didn't you if
they're not sufficiently shocked if
nothing changes will you then think
about slaughtering the pair got it out
what no we wanted to provoke a
discussion but we're not going to
slaughter any other animals